[Music]
lady gaga just posted some cryptic
videos teasing a very personal new
project
today gaga instagram behind the scenes
footage from super bowl 51 now part of
her upcoming documentary i was there as
it all went down
what was it like being so suspended in
the air you know i just i've made a
decision about a month ago that i was
going to do it and i went for it
but what
111 million tv viewers didn't see
her health struggles leading up to the
epic halftime performance let's try to
get you get out of this intense pain
that's in your face in gaga 5'2 coming
to netflix mother monster details her
treatments for both physical pain let's
try to get the muscles to re-educate and
psychological pain you can hear her
break down in this clip and all these
people will leave
right last year gaga and beyonce taylor
kinney broke off their five-year
relationship in her new film the 31 year
old tearfully tells designer friend
brandon maxwell she's lonely i'm alone
brandon every night i go from everyone
touching me all day and talking at me
all day
to total silence
also in the film gaga mentions her
rumored rival me and madonna i admired
her always and i still admire her no
matter what she might think of me what
you think about lady gaga it feels
uh reductive the only thing that really
bothers me about her
uh yeah that clip cuts out before we get
the answer
[Music]